some staggering figures from our
Southern border since the beginning of
December there have been more than
286,000 migrant encounters there since
the new fiscal year began on October 1st
there have been more than 770,000
encounters with more than
83,500 known Goda ways migrants seen or
detected but not apprehended joining me
now two Texas congressmen whose
districts touch the Mexican border
Republican Tony Gonzalez and Democrat
Henry quar gentlemen
welcome thank you thank you Mike so some
eye popping numbers in terms of illegal
immigrants coming to the United States
Congressman qu if President Biden's
watching right now what would you tell
him he needs to
do he needs to look at the pull factor
and the pull factor right now is that as
long as people are coming to the border
and they feel that they're hidden a
speed bumped and they're they're being
released and waiting four five 6 years
for an adjudication then they're going
to keep coming it's the pull factor if
we don't address that by addressing
detention giving them the the quick
hearing and then deporting most of them
are going to be deported because Asylum
cases if you look at the last 25 years
87% are going to be uh rejected so why
are we allowing 100% when we ought to be
looking at smaller point so it's the
pull factor you got to have detention
and deportation Congressman giv you've
invited speaker Mike Johnson and some
leading Republicans to the Border this
week to be fair though wouldn't it be
more effective if you had Democrats
coming as
well well step one in solving the Border
crisis is getting all Republicans to get
on board I I I have hosted uh Democrats
as well and I'd love to host anyone
who's willing to come to the Border uh
life along the border has turned upside
down and that's exactly what the speaker
and my colleagues are going to see next
week you know I I believe in legal
immigration I believe most of America
believes in legal immigration but what
we're seeing is not that this is chaos
and so enough is enough it's time to
deport those that illegally come into
the United States and President Biden
can either do that or he can watch and
lose and watch the next president uh
enforce those policies that are on the
books uh hosting speaker Johnson next
week is very critical to getting House
Republicans on board uh I'm expecting at
least 60 of my uh rep Republican
colleagues to join us on that visit uh
we're going to be an Eagle pass we're
going to be hearing from directly from
people on the ground uh these these
stories are going to resignate and it's
going to it's going to lead us House
Republicans into 2024 as we try to
tackle these issues the Justice
Department's going after your Governor
Greg Abbott planning to sue over the
Texas anti-immigration law threatening
quote to pursue all appropriate legal
remedies to ensure that Texas does not
interfere with the functions of the
federal government do you support the
doj on that Congressman
qu well first of all let's keep in mind
that there is a federal law that says
that if you come into the United States
it's a misdemeanor and then if you keep
doing it it becomes a felony so there's
already something there my only concern
is and I understand the state of Texas
there is a frustration and I join them
in that frustration my only thing is the
only ones that are trained to do
immigration law or border patrol it's
not the military it's not the Texas DPS
or the local officials that's my concern
it's the training part of it but I join
them in the frustration but there is a
federal law that says that if you come
here illegally then it's either a
misdemeanor or a felony and I think it's
about time that the federal government
starts enforcing uh the books including
ttle late Congressman Gonzalez your
thoughts on the doj going after the
governor yeah no they sue us we sue them
round and round we go meanwhile Henry
and I both together have over 50% of the
Southern border and we are the ones
seeing it every single day and we want
Solutions enough with the finger
pointing enough with the lawyers getting
rich with these lawsuits we want real
tangible border Security Solutions that
keep Americans safe and not only that
like we're going to demand that and I'd
argue there there will be no border
package that doesn't include Henry quar
and Tony Gonzalez's uh consent and or
input on making sure that they're real
tangible Solutions because we live it
every single day the Secretary of State
and the homeland security secretary
traveled to Mexico this week there was a
joint statement basically talking about
a variety of issues and house Speaker
Mike Johnson is furious about what came
out of that saying quote secretaries my
orcus and blinkin discussed with the
president of Mexico amnesty for illegal
immigrants do you worry about amnesty uh
talk attracting people and not deterring
them Congressman
qu no look the last time we had amnesty
was in 1986 you had a democratic
Congress and you had a Republican
president Ronald Reagan that was the
last time I don't support that but I
think what Tony and I are trying to do
is trying to figure out how do we stop
these large numbers of people coming in
Tony and I were actually down there with
Senator Corin uh Chris Murphy and other
members well we spent about 5 hours with
the president of Mexico we just got to
make sure understand each other we don't
want Mexico to interfere with our
foreign policy or with our laws but we
want them to do their job the more we
stop people on their 20 yard line which
is Mexico and Guatemala then the better
it is for us here then we got enforc
Tate deportation and of course uh
detention also Congressman Gonzalez was
the visit to Mexico by the cabinet
secretaries just a photo
op I think it's more than a photo op I
think it's uh the Secretary of State
doing his job and I thank him for doing
his job and visiting some of these
countries for too long they've the
Administration has relied on DHS
secretary blinkin but I'm going to be
very clear here there will be no amnesty
in any National Security package I will
make sure of that I am looking for real
tangible solutions that is a dog whistle
to the left that essentially tries to
get them on board I don't I'm not not
worried about the politics in it uh I'm
seeing Americans do not feel safe in
their homes own homes I'm feel I'm
seeing fentanyl killing Americans I'm
seeing cities all over the country right
now we're talking about New York City
and Chicago but next year we're going to
be talking about Denver and la and and
Philadelphia there is no end of this
border crisis until there are real
tangible Solutions and that starts with
enforcing those that come over illegal
in our country you Deport them back to
their country of origin okay when you
gentlemen return to Capitol Hill funding
will be really a critical issue facing a
January 19th deadline after a couple of
short-term punts um will you guys get a
deal through September the 30th
Congressman
quer well you know both Tony and I are
uh appropriators and we certainly want
to make sure that uh we fund the
Appropriations uh Bill especially
Homeland Appropriations bills uh you
know we do have January 19th and then we
have the February 2nd then in between
there we we got to see if we're going to
work out a deal on the border and of
course Ukraine and the other areas
Israel so those are the things we need
to look at but as appropriators we want
to make sure we don't have a shutdown we
want to make sure that we fund the
government appropriately Congressman
Gonzalez do you worry about another
short-term funding
extension I do uh if you thought the
politics in 2023 were fun just wait
until 2024 it is going to be lightning
uh it's going to be nonstop uh once
again Henry and I sit on the
Appropriations Committee I have been
pushing to pass these conservative
appropriation packages that that that
have gone through the house work with
the Senate come up with a deal I voted
against the last continuous resolution I
voted against the previous continuing
resolution before that and I will vote
against the next continuing resolution
unless there are re meaningful border
Solutions in there you can count me as a
no on any continuing resolution all
right Congressman Gonzalez Congressman
qu are thanks very much hey everyone I'm
Emily compano catch me and my co-hosts
Harris vulner and Kaye mcaneny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights